don't bring anyone into this I feel like
the weasel you could have found that guy
anywhere on the sunset Sunset Strip in
that era of time because it was like the
the metal clubs you remember and like
the Sunset Strip was kind of that dude
very well could have been living there
yeah how did you how did he come to you
well first of all before you even answer
that can we start so that people know
that Paulie like where he grew up
oh my god craziest life ever like they
taste like so that they know the
background your your mother Mitzi shore
the oh my god yeah it just goes don't
bring me in on this bullshit mom you
know ran the comedy store and probably
basically grew up at the Comedy Store
yes of course and and I've met your debt
and and there's you know he's got Sam
Kinison babysitting him and crazy and
Rodney and just as crazy as throughout
he was the best really oh my god so
hilarious just oh yeah oh yeah he was
the best I believe that yeah he was the
best and sweetheart and funny and all
that stuff to Cristina's point do you at
an early age because it's almost it
seems normal to you do you go like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do with all
these people might I have two brothers
and a sister and they're not into it so
it's like they grew up in it as well I
mean you guys know you guys are straight
comics you guys are hardcore comics like
you don't choose it it chooses you like
like you live fucking in the valley like
you guys have to drive to the calmness
or deal do you think you like driving
the comments or no yeah but you fucking
know once you get up there gonna have
that feeling and that you know that
especially you guys got to drive to the
fucking Airport yeah and fly to you know
all over America do you like that no but
you know what's gonna happen when you
get there right people are gonna be
there for you and your heart is gonna be
open you're gonna feel this like stress
reliever you own a mean so is your first
at the store no I stayed away from it
for about two years and but you were
like did you mom because I knew well I
started when I was like 17 I started
when I
to Beverly Hills High School and I was
like in uh I was in it was in high
school is at the beginning of 12th grade
and all my friends were going to college
they were taking the SAT papers and I'm
like okay now I got a start so I just
started angel Salazar actually wrote my
first joke he wrote my first joke so he
got me he got you know these car I got
these comics to start kind of writing me
jokes because I didn't know how to write
jokes and then my dad took me to my
first gig he did do you feel pressure
because it was your father or did you
feel supported because it was your
father do you know I mean it can be
either way um no he was cool you know he
was cool my dad was cool you know but I
always like you know was it was just one
of those things that I always knew I was
gonna do and like okay now I'm gonna do
it but I stayed away from the store for
two years and then there was a club
called the alley cat Bistro and that
wasn't no that was where I was my first
know the LA Cabaret was a club in the
valley you remember yeah it's not it's
not there anymore though yeah yeah like
Encino yeah so a guy named ray Bishop
who used to own an Argus Hamilton used
to get me spots there and then I worked
with Jamie at the Laugh Factory for
years really yes I stayed away from the
store and then the first time I went on
from my mom I showcased for her and then
what kind of pressure was that
terrifying yeah I was a nightmare it was
yeah that's a nightmare cuz I also
figured you either gonna be like no it's
no big deal or yeah it's the fucking
night no I was fucking terrible I was 19
you mean and did she tell you well let
me finish okay no no so so Paul Mooney
in lieu in Paul Mooney and Louie
Anderson were sitting next to her in the
booth and her booth so I go on stage
it's packed
obviously there's like a wall full of
comics I don't wanna say they hate my
guts but it's Mitzi's son you know so
they're like in the way back so I'm like
I'm like on stage I'm doing these really
bad jokes that angel told me for me I
grew up in Beverly Hills my mom's
Mexican whatever what am i right I say
my jokes no laughs so at the end I break
out and start pop locking I had this
boom box we play freakazoid and I put
this mask on my stick because I was good
up
yeah so I started popping and then after
I went off stage I ended good eye for
when I'm like how did I do it she's like
stick with the dancing
my mom said stick with the dancing and
then she's like get away from me it was
like pretty bad yeah so like it's not
till I became famous on MTV and I was
like drawing people in the main room
that she like made me a paid regular
really yeah yeah we had to stay away and
then I worked with Denison for a long
time well what did you wait who I wanted
to do with Kinison what do you mean you
worked with an you opened for him yeah I
opened for him Wow so is that the birth
of the weasel how does the weasel cuz
that the damn I have to say it was kind
of like all my friends used to call me
the weasel they did
yeah like when I was younger and then a
lot of comics like Jackson Perdue he
said you're a weasel mm-hmm and then I
was always like we so like I'm the one
that kind of came up with that and then
I was like if some one kid is if that
noise can actually occur what would that
noise sound like and I was like you know
that's where that the thing came and
then I started like pausing between my
words dad that was on MTV yeah that's
yeah that was like I would look in the
camera be like check out this video bro
cuz it's gonna be May and then I would
just start making shit up right and then
it was like my own language to the
audience and then and then from there
you know I was like kind of had my own
slang to the audio wheezing the juice
that was from Encino man no so that's
how it took off the thing about it is
like as a kid to you know like somebody
who's a little bit older than you and is
cool so cool and then and then when you
learn slack because you're as a kid it's
like what does that mean yeah so like it
was hearing the slang on MTV but then in
the movies too that you're like oh man
and then you do it on the playground you
pretend to be cool crazy
Pauly Shore at school it was pretty cool
yeah it was cool yeah that's why I was
dope
[Music]